let's go next to our caller from the 562
area code who's there from five six to
hello yeah that's you what's your name
oh hey David uh yeah I just have a quick
quick question
okay what's your name oh yeah my name is
Jose Arevalo I'm calling from Long Beach
California oh cool love Long Beach all
right so let's say is Bernie went to a
run for president in terms of like a
percentage what do you think his chances
are winning of winning the primary or of
winning the entire thing they have the
entire thing well I mean listen if
there's ten candidates then from a
merely mathematical perspective there's
a 10% chance Bernie wins the primary and
then a 50% chance Bernie wins the
election which makes it a five percent
chance right I mean that's strictly
speaking from like a mathematical
perspective so I don't I think that yeah
we have to sort of there's this is it's
much more complicated to really think
about it will question one when does
Bernie announce the longer he waits I
think the more problematic it is for him
number two what's the role of the DNC
within the primary this year to what
degree are they going to put their
finger on the scales does Bernie even
win the primary if he doesn't that's
gonna drastically reduce his chance of
winning so I don't know but I think your
more general question correct me if I'm
wrong is just how do I assess Bernie's
chances if he gets into this race
yeah sure well I'm just wondering
because you know his previous campaign
you know he kind of like gained a lot of
popularity so yeah I'm just wondering
like if his chances are like bigger than
they were before I think that at this
point the advantage Bernie would have
compared to 2016 if he runs is that he
is far more recognizable he has far more
policy ideas out there that people are
generally like and I think that he would
have immediate frontrunner status I'm
not saying the number one frontrunner
but he would immediately be in the top
tier as opposed to last time where he
had to spend months just getting
corporate media to pay attention to him
so I do think he'd be better positioned
than in 2016 yeah okay thanks thanks for
calling from
from Long Beach love Long Beach